[Music]
please carry me please what carried this
is your fourth movie together right but
it had been I think about 10 years what
was it like for you two to be together
on set again to reunite it was the best
yeah that's what makes him the best um
pretty much anything I've always I mean
he's one of my favorite people to work
with to be around and yeah and I feel
the same I knew I knew that it was the
movie would only work with like someone
a really strong chemistry with and I
I've always felt like we did we did what
do you love about working with her a
good friend sense of humor intelligence
my view of the world beautiful heart
beautiful spirit and a damn foreigner
Winona Ryder and Keanu Reeves can't stop
gushing over each other while talking
about their new romantic comedy
destination wedding you might as well
just stick us together I don't want to
be a person you don't know where to
stick do you guys remember the first
time that you met having worked together
on all these movies for all these years
now
I do I I met him it was at and we
presented an award at the Independent
Spirit Awards back when it was like you
know room building chairs yeah low-key
yeah
but there was like it wasn't kind of
what is what it is today but I remember
us very very excited okay this is
memorable you remember the exact we were
you met each other why is that well I
have
I had a pretty and and you know anyway
what happened to the healthy crushes you
believe there's someone for everyone
close the co-stars are looking for love
and haven't ruled out the idea of
getting married one day this movie is so
much about a wedding does did working on
it make you guys think about ever
getting married do you see yourselves
whether it's to each other anyone else
ever going down that road I mean it
would be nice can you come out of this
film that yeah you think about things
like that and and if you don't think it
can be possible or drunk then maybe this
will change that perspective like oh
there Kent I can't this can happen I
can't connect with something like this
and and if you do then it's you know
it's great so yeah get on this toast
yeah me too
keeps love alive yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]